[OPENING CREDITS]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Hi,
I'm Natalie Villalobos,
here at Big Android BBQ in
Hurst, Texas with Stacy Devino.
She's an Android
developer, and I just
wanted to ask her a
couple of questions
before we all depart the
great state of Texas.
Hey Stacy, how are you doing?
STACY DEVINO: Doing just fine.
Ready for some meat.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So
I see these pins on you.
Can you tell me a little
bit about the culture
of these pins, and
how many years you've
been coming to Big Android BBQ.
STACY DEVINO: These
are just the pins
I've accumulated pretty
much from this BBQ
and Google I/O-- there was a big
Android event also held, like,
as an after party.
So yeah, I've been
coming-- gosh,
this is probably my
fourth year, I think.
It might be fifth.
I can't tell.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And so, it's
a part of the Android culture
to get pins from different
companies that are represented
at Android events?
STACY DEVINO: Oh, no.
This is a big Android thing.
This is not-- but uh-- no,
it's all about representation
and it's so fabulous that
these guys actually support us.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah, yeah.
It's really cool, you
have like Facebook,
you have Golden Gate Bridge.
You have some startups,
too, that were also present.
So it's really cool to see that.
So I wanted to get started.
How did you get into
mobile development?
Like, why Android?
STACY DEVINO: So I started
really young, with a Palm.
So I first learned on
Palm C in middle school,
because my dad worked
for 3Com at the time.
And then that just
kept on progressing.
And did stuff with
iPods, and then
initially some iPhone stuff.
But we won't talk
so much about that.
But then Android
came on the scene,
and they didn't call it hacking.
They called it development.
And that's what really
attracted me to Android.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And
what was your first project
that you were proud of?
Or maybe, you even had
challenges on, but that
at the end of the day, once
you solved for it, it was--
that's when you knew--
STACY DEVINO: I did some--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Your first love.
STACY DEVINO: So I did some work
for the military and emergency
services, and put out
a product by myself
in a very, very
short time frame that
was kind of revolutionizing
for the industry.
And I just-- I literally
worked 120 hours one week.
And 90 hours was my average.
So it was-- it was
one of those things
that I just was-- I couldn't
believe I was capable of it.
And you can be amazed what
you can push yourself through.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Yeah, so when
you're in those stressful
moments, what makes you calm?
Or what-- or what is the tool
that you use to persevere?
Is it long walks on the beach?
Is it--
STACY DEVINO:
Really, it's a belief
that the world was basically
revolutionized by people
no smarter, no more
capable than you are.
So what's stopping you from
achieving what they did?
And there-- it's
just an inner fire.
Keep trying until you fail.
And then fail again.
And then-- as long as
time's still available,
fail as many times as you
can till you get it right.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So one of things
that I love about you
is that you're a maker.
In a lot of different
capacities, right?
So you're an Android maker, if
you were to say it that way.
But you also have been getting
into a lot of 3D printing,
and you're a member of
the Dallas Makerspace.
Can you tell me a little
bit why-- about why making
is so important.
STACY DEVINO: So making is
the ability to take your ideas
and make them tangible.
And the ability to communicate
and learn from people
beyond just work,
beyond just what people
might think that
you should know.
I mean, some of my best friends
are both software developers
and blacksmiths.
Things that you wouldn't
actually consider,
but it really gives you
that-- that-- this is only so
satisfying sometimes.
Sometimes you just need
to craft something,
do something creative.
And, you know, ultimately
at the end of the day,
you can't rely on
your employer to 100%
provide everything for you
in terms of creativity.
You have to go and make
yourself a multi-faceted person.
And that actually
ends up opening
a lot of opportunities at work.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah,
so one of the things
I just wanted to share with
our developers at home,
Stacy is also a Women
Techmakers lead,
and so she created us
these really cool custom
Women Techmakers
Android figurines
that I'm going to be taking back
to my desk in Mountain View.
So speaking of that, you're
a Women Techmakers lead,
can you tell me what you
think the industry needs
to do to support more women to
come into Android development
or to be a designer or maybe
a founder of her own startup?
STACY DEVINO: So
this is something
I've actually talked
about with leaders
of pretty well-known companies.
It's not that we need
to encourage more.
It's just that we need
to discourage less.
We just need to tell somebody,
hey, you know, it's OK.
Something didn't go right.
There's a lot of
feelings as a woman
that you have to be
everything to everyone.
And when you say, it's OK
if something had a bug,
other person had a
bug two weeks ago.
It's OK.
You're going to do well.
So by actually not even just
encouraging, but just don't
discourage them, you know?
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah, and
also don't give up, right?
I think that failure
is OK, but-- and I
also think that
when you're failing,
having a supportive team that
says, oh, yeah, I failed too.
Right?
It's almost like creating a
supportive network of failure.
So that no one actually
leaves the industry--
STACY DEVINO: The
circle of failure.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
The circle of failure.
Yeah, exactly.
So you know, I think
that you're right.
When we create that kind
of ecosystem and community,
like Big Android BBQ, right?
All these people
are here and are
a supportive network for when
you're developing something.
STACY DEVINO: Right.
Oh, totally.
I mean, I can't tell you
how many times, like,
I've seen Virginia's
artwork paired
with like another one of my
friend's development skills.
And they just come out with
this totally cool thing
that they just did
after work one weekend.
I mean, and we see the same
people at the same events,
but that's because
they're our friends.
They're our network.
And when I have
trouble with something,
I know exactly who to
go to for that problem.
And it ultimately makes
you a better developer.
And a better person too.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
Well, I know we all got
to get down to the BBQ.
That's what we came here for,
besides Android development.
STACY DEVINO: Yes, meat.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So I just want
to say thank you so much for
coming out and talking to us.
And thanks so much for being
a great Women Techmakers lead,
as well.
STACY DEVINO: Oh, thank
you very much, Natalie.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So, Natalie Villalobos
again bringing some
live insights and tips
from Stacy at Big Android BBQ.
I think this concludes our
interviews for Big Android BBQ
and just tune in more for Women
Techmakers sessions coming up.
[CLOSING CREDITS]